how do we define a living wage general
definition is living wage as a wage sort
of high enough to maintain a normal
standard of living sort of baked okay so
how can we make it more specific well
living wage means you can afford shelter
food and basic necessities of life
without using more than 30 percent of
your income towards housing alone so a
study was done by the national Low
Income Housing Coalition and it points
out maybe not surprisingly but really
disappointingly that no one in the
United States working full-time making
the minimum wage can afford a
two-bedroom apartment in any of the 50
states of the United States of America
not in Arkansas not in Wyoming in no US
state regardless of cost of living based
on the federal minimum wage working
full-time at the federal minimum wage of
725 an hour is roughly $15,000 a year
full-time minimum wage workers anywhere
in the country would have to make about
twice that in order to afford a
two-bedroom apartment an American making
the federal minimum wage of 725 would
have to work 95 hours a week or more
than two full-time jobs to afford a
two-bedroom apartment if you're a single
mom working 40 hours a week at minimum
wage and you want to have your own room
tough luck Alaska Washington Colorado
Florida Virginia Illinois you have to
make over 20 dollars an hour to afford
at full time a two-bedroom apartment in
California you've got to make thirty
dollars an hour to be able to afford a
two-bedroom apartment in Washington DC
thirty-three dollars an hour in Hawaii
thirty-five dollars an hour and we as
you're going to see here almost anywhere
you're going to find something that's
near the threshold you are going to need
to earn according to this graphic 21
dollars and 21 cents on average to
afford a two-bedroom apartment why can't
these people to stop being so poor pad
and pull themselves up by their own
bootstraps
Danah or or live in a one-bedroom
apartment I guess yeah that's right Lou
anytime a study like this is done you
hear bright wingers and people who say
we should have no minimum wage or it
shouldn't be any higher they say why do
all these people need two bedroom
apartments anyway
I mean why why do everybody should just
live in a one-bedroom apartment I mean
it makes sense if you live in New York
City or Boston or San Francisco places
where the rent is so high there's a lot
of income disparity and yeah there's a
tech industry there but if you're in the
middle of the country say you're in
Wyoming you should be able to afford
that working forty hours a week you
deserve you've got to applaud states
like Illinois and New York that are
introducing a $15 minimum wage but it's
still not enough for a two-bedroom
apartment in many parts of those states
properties are also overvalued in the
United States in general but lawmakers
that that's sort of different issue
lawmakers can look at there are many
places in the country where a full time
minimum wage job won't even get you a
dignified one-bedroom apartment and
you're sort of alluding to that pad many
people naively look around at this $15
minimum wage proposal and they say oh my
god it's some radical communist
abstraction that's crazy it's now part
of the DNC platform for a good reason
even though Hillary Clinton for some
reason wanted a 12 rather than $15
minimum wage we can probably thank
Bernie Sanders at least in part for that
but it's still not even that much right
and this isn't an entitlement or a
handout you're working for this money
and if you work a 40-hour a week job I
mean you should be able to afford basic
things like food like health care
absolutely shelter I mean that's first
and foremost if we want to think about
this in one other way and I think you
probably can predict where I'm going
because I've talked about this before
basic income right even if we don't
increase the minimum wage or restructure
other aspects of the economy and work
culture forget about all of that even
just the 750 dollar a month
basic income which is $9,000 per year
which is sort of on the low end right
you I would like to see more done as a
basic income but let's say you did that
even that would push many many people
not everyone by any means given how much
housing costs in many parts of this
country but that would push many people
closer to being able to actually afford
housing and let me mention something
else the reason for this 30% limit right
you're generally the idea
you don't spend more than 30% of your
income on housing the reason for that
limit is because of some of the other
expenses people have if we moved in the
direction of single-payer health care
and disconnected health insurance from
work you could also then make housing
more affordable for people just by
virtue of not having to reserve as much
money for health care and the minimum
wage also brings up a conversation about
corporate welfare because if you have
companies out there like Walmart paying
their workers 725 an hour those people
still have to get by and they're going
to do so based on you know government
programs that maybe food stamps that
maybe public housing so in a roundabout
sort of way we're paying for their
corporate profits absolutely and this is
something we've talked about before
which is you have many of these
businesses which are touted as the sort
of be-all end-all of efficiency and
profitability and the American Dream
because they employ so many people yeah
they employ so many people at in many
cases below subsistence level wages and
how is that money being made up it's
being made up by government programs
which are funded by your tax dollars so
this idea that people have of it's a
great business decision how Walmart and
other companies have structured and
they're totally self-sufficient they're
not self sufficient sufficient many of
their employees would literally die if
it weren't for the fact that they're
making up some money either in terms of
welfare programs food stamps whatever
the case may be
Medicaid through taxpayer funded
government welfare programs if you
eliminate that McDonald's and Walmart
are far less viable as businesses but of
course a right-winger would say well we
should just take out food stamps and
public housing all right all these
social safety nets to begin with but
then why even have a government
untenable untenable and you know however
you want to approach the solutions to
this problem and people reasonable
people can differ about the best way to
approach it this is not sustainable
that's what I think many people are
missing sort of going about their day
like there's something even remotely
sustainable about this when there isn't
there isn't it's going to break one way
or another it's sort of already breaking
and it's broken already for many many
people send me your thoughts about this
what do you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is
Twitter at David Pakman show talk to me
there today's program is made possible
by taga Deb the hosting specialists
offering a range of flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options as well as custom
server solutions and uk-based colocation
services for your business or project
taga DAV's web hosting services support
a wide range of customers and businesses
worldwide including bloggers tech
startups financial traders gamers web
developers and more and taga dad has a
really user-friendly interface so you
don't have to worry about being super
tech savvy they can automate almost
everything you need for total ease of
use they are really proud of their team
of expert hosting specialists who are
also their support team 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab is currently offering our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all customers signing up to
give you a chance to try the service
this is a limited availability offer
first-come first-served for viewers and
listeners of the David Pakman show to
take advantage of it go to signup CagA
Deb comm /t DPS and use the offer code
TDPS 20 all one word all lowercase
during account registration